okay let's get started
as you know usually or when I'm here
introduce the speaker but since I'm the
speaker today and you all know me at
least most of you do I guess I'll just
go ahead and start I guess for I maybe
recognize maybe don't recognize one or
two faces in the crowd so my name's bill
Hirsch I'm the chair of the department
and also director of the program and
most years I kick off the conference
series often times kind of giving an
update of what's happening in the field
and that that's actually sort of what
this is but I'm gonna shift the focus a
little bit to focus just on the
educational program there's obviously a
lot of other exciting things happening
in informatics but I'm gonna focus on
the educational program in part because
as you know we sometimes use this
conference for practice talks and there
is actually an educators collaborative
that has been formed in the School of
Medicine and they have a grand round
series and so they they were looking for
speakers so I volunteered to speak I
always want to talk about our program
and so I'm actually giving that talk
next week which will largely be these
slides but what I'm actually going to do
though is some of the things that will
be clear review to you all I will go
through very quickly and then what I'd
like to do is to leave a little time at
the end and get some feedback not only
about the talk but the program if
there's any issues people want to bring
up let me then also ask someone to
monitor the Twitter feed the demise comp
Twitter feed because there's potentially
people listening out there and we like
to take questions that way
in addition to from the audience and and
when we do the questions now we're
getting away from these awful mics and
so I think Lynne has the microphone the
the purpose of which is so people who
are either listening into the webinar or
listening later can actually hear the
questions so this talk as you know once
a month we call this conference in
addition to the device research
conference the clinical informatics
Grand Rounds which actually is related
to our clinical informatics fellowship
and actually enables physicians to get
continuing medical education credit so
people have to make a statement of any
disclosures stock that they own and so
forth
so I'm happy to report that I have no
relevant financial or commercial
interests or disclosures to report
although actually I probably do have a
conflict of interest here because I get
paid to teach informatics that's what I
do for a living but technically that's
not a conflict of interest so anyways
and when we do Grand Rounds we also have
to present learning objectives so this
is a kind of longer version of the table
of contents for my talk so the part I'm
really gonna go fast through because you
probably don't want to hear me talk
about it is defining our field I will
talk about some of the competencies that
have been developed for various types of
informaticians I'll talk about the
accomplishments of the program which
many of you know many of you are part of
those accomplishments and then describe
what I think are some of the lessons
that we've learned from this whole
experience literally over a quarter
century since we first had our NLM
training grant awarded in 1992 when I
was a
assistant professor ok so again I'm
gonna go through these quickly because
many of you have seen these slides but I
think you all know my view of
Informatics of the intersection of
people information and technology we
have a lot of adjectives that we put in
front of Informatics depending on
whether we're talking about informatics
about genomes or people or populations
or images etc and I think that's ok
although sometimes it creates conflict
when we're trying to more precisely
define the field informatics has become
a core competency of healthcare the
Institute of Medicine now called the
National Academy of Medicine published a
report in 2003 on the the confidence
that health professionals need to
provide patient centered care and one of
the circles leading to that Venn diagram
is utilize informatics informatics
competencies are not just computer
literacy it's kind of a battle that I
have fought over the years scars to show
for it
explaining to people that informatics is
just not about computers
obviously even though we enjoy working
with computers but it's really about the
information and in fact there well we
for example with medical students we
know that they come in they all are very
computer savvy email messaging fakes
Facebook etc but that doesn't
necessarily mean they're good
information users and I suppose we can
actually say that about informatics
students too so we need to teach good
information skills informatics is also
part of more recently this No
shouldn't have a third science so that
traditional two sciences of medicine our
basic science and clinical science the
recent years have kind of coalesced this
idea of a third science about it was
originally called healthcare delivery
science which I actually like that term
but for whatever reason it's now called
Health System science just the idea that
medicine and healthcare are more than
just biology and clinical it's really
about systems how you deliver care the
quality of care that you deliver
cost-effectiveness etc and informatics
is listed as one of the core domains of
Health System science there's actually a
book that's been published and I was
asked to write the informatics chapter
in that book and so that's another way
to look at informatics informatics is
also important for physicians as you all
know it's now a subspecialty of all
specialties there's for over fourteen
hundred board-certified physicians
including few of us in this room we also
have a new fellowship I like to mention
that a little bit and I think even
though there's actually some issues I
actually think it's been a good
development for the informatics field
but informatics is not just about
physicians there are many others who
work in informatics coming from other
health professions life sciences IT etc
and in fact amia is developing a
advanced health informatics
certification although there's some
issues around it who is going to be
eligible for it but the point is that
informatics is about more than positions
and informaticians really play a role
now across the
Healthcare Enterprise whether it's
academia research health care delivery
etc I think we've kind of reached a
point now where most people in health
care know what informatics is though
they're still occasionally confusion
there this part you may be less familiar
with but another thing that's happened
in the field is the defining of
competencies it's actually something
that's happened in education rather than
just think we need to have people
memorize some body of knowledge we
actually want to determine what they
need to do to function in their
workforce roles whether they're
professionals or researchers or
educators or whatever so there have been
the development of competency sets or
different types of in well for for
informaticians but also for you'll see
one set which we actually developed and
they're known for here actually for
medical students although in reality
it's applicable to pretty much all
Health Professions so there's a lot of
text on these slides and my goal even
with the audience next week isn't that
to read through them all but to just
show you the competency sets but to
really look at it from the standpoint of
the big picture and I have references
will distribute these slides around for
those who want to look at them but one
set of competencies is the core
competencies for biomedical informatics
that was developed by a Mia and
published in 2012 this set of
competencies actually applies to most of
us in this room who do informatics and
it's I like this set of common like all
these set of competencies actually but I
like this one because it really
describes what
we do as informaticians we don't just go
in and install software and hope that
it'll work or I think that it's going to
work but we first of all we acquire the
professional perspective in informatics
and that we there I believe that there
really is an informatics way of looking
at information related problems keeping
in mind and and this is true whether
you're in bioinformatics or clinical
informatics but keeping in mind the
importance of information of standards
of people's workflow security actually
just met this morning with the new chief
information security officer who I'm
going to have come here and give us a
talk he's a very interesting person and
will hopefully uh sure in a new era of
security but as implementations we think
about these things we don't think about
workarounds and do the brilliant thing
that our surgical residents who didn't
really know better but when the epic
patient sign out tool was not meeting
their needs they just created a Google
Doc and thousands of OHSU patients
sitting in an unsecure Google Doc which
is one actually one of the reasons why
that chief information security officer
is here because of our HIPAA fine
anyways but the point is to acquire that
professional perspective point of view
to analyze people's problems so
understand what it is that they want to
do and bring our perspective on the
different types of data and information
that people use produce solutions for
them implement them evaluate them refine
them and in the process innovating and
collaborating and sharing our results
with the rest of the world so that's one
set of competencies
the in the development of the clinical
informatics subspecialty which really
represents the informatics becoming a
more of a professional role when some of
the s-- in the room here who are older
came into the field there really wasn't
much of in a professional role for
informatics most implementations were
academic researchers what's really
happened over the last 10 or 15 years is
the huge growth of mostly in healthcare
organizations but also in research
organizations of informatics
professionals who really have a
professional role and again i won't go
through all the details here but it's a
similar sort of thing of being able to
do things like an information needs
analysis coming up with the solution in
the case of informatics professional
since you're often buying versus
building software being able to issue
the involved in the issuing of RFPs to
evaluate vendor responses to those sorts
of things and implementing commercial
software like we do in the hospital now
with epic and and all the other
operational systems also being able
though to evaluate and generalize the
findings so this one is the comes from
the paper that our group here published
around competencies it was written for
medical students but and it was written
for medical students because it was
funded by a grant that was for medical
students and was published in a medical
education journal but in reality these
competencies are really what every
healthcare professional who
practicing medicine nursing pharmacy
physical therapy etc in the 21st century
needs to know and we retitled it since a
lot of people think well healthcare
professionals they need to use the EHR
they need to know how to search but they
need to know more and so while those two
things are most prominent right at the
beginning there is other things in the
clinical setting clinicians need to
understand what clinical decision
support is and does how they can be
involved in tailoring it for their
organization understanding things like
population health management as we move
towards value-based care and medicine
protecting patient privacy and security
understanding the the the importance of
that the ramifications of it trying to
not have people do workarounds patient
safety quality management and
improvement health information exchange
understand why we still haven't reached
the point where you're a patient
somewhere and you go get care somewhere
else and your information seamlessly
goes there or in the case often though
it doesn't go there professionalism the
whole how we act as professionals with
information how we behave on social
media which sometimes my children accuse
me of overstepping bounds all the
patient engagement personal health
records research telemedicine things
like that so that's this set of
competencies and then there's also a set
of competencies for researchers and I
actually just I didn't find a way to
incorporate it in but I just came across
a few days ago actually paper on
bioinformatics
competencies for undergraduates I'll
have to work that into this one but this
comes mostly out of the CTSA program and
I was a little bit involved in this in
terms of what what do researchers need
to know researchers need to know for
example that they shouldn't be carrying
around their pH I data on an unencrypted
thumb drive which unfortunately happens
they need to understand the value and
but the limitations of things like
clinical data sources that they have
access to integrating omics data with
clinical data etc they will rely on
people like us as professionals to help
them do that but they have to have at
least a basic understanding of what they
can and can't do with information so let
me run through all the great
accomplishments which you all know about
because you're part of but maybe
summarize it all because some of you may
be in parts of the program where you're
not as aware of what's happening in the
rest of the program but we've done a lot
over the years and you know OHSU is
certainly known in this area and so
obviously our graduate program right now
consisting of our PhD and two masters
and graduate certificate it's been
around a while I've written about it
other people written about it and it's
offered in different modalities on the
in the clinical informatics track it's
offered online for the graduate
certificate the MBI and it can be done
for the MS we're actually some of you
know about this in the process of making
some name and other structural changes
and we stepped into a hornet's nest
things that needed to get approved so we
are in the process Believe It or Not of
going through the whole program approval
process that I actually first went
through with the master's program 22
years ago and but we're confident that
we'll make it out of that actually diane
has put a ton of effort Andrea as well
and hopefully in the neck after several
months this will all be behind us but
what we do it well but it all started
because we just wanted to make some name
changes in the tracks clinical
informatics broadening it to call it
health and clinical informatics BCP
changing the word biology to biomedicine
to kind of reflect the more data science
orientation of the BCB tract and and
it's not just about biology and omics
anymore it has clinical data imaging etc
when we did that the the Provost's
office actually decided that the tracks
had actually become distinct from each
other and in fact there's this whole
movement in education away from using
the word tracks so about six or nine
months from now you'll hear us talk
about majors some of you will be BCB
majors others of you will be health and
clinical informatics majors and we we
also want it to take the as long as we
were making changes no one really knows
what an MBI is although X I mean there's
so many people that have it that you see
them but we're the only place I think
that has a degree called MBI
anyways we we did that because in the
old days if you didn't do it this Asst
people didn't want to call it a master
of science well now the world has
changed and any master's degree can be
called a master of science so will soon
be master of science wit thesis and
master of science without theses so
that's what you'll be able to call your
degrees anyways so we're working on this
and we'll let you know when it happens
our numbers continue to go up we as of
June now have awarded 738 degrees and
certificates to six hundred and sixty
six people some people have more than
one some people like to collect them and
we have many international
collaborations both international
students who come here and students to
whom we deliver education so last week I
was in Thailand and our was teaching a
group of students who had basically done
the equivalent of BMI 510 online
delivered on Sakai to Thailand we
delivered the Singapore and where else
around the world and our students live
all over the place depending on the
audience I would like to point out that
most of the cities of the NLM training
grant sites are have dots on that map
those dots are where our online students
live or at least a few years ago we need
to update this we have our fellowship
programs which many of you in the room
are involved with we just got re upped
or our NLM training grant
unfortunately they wanted to increase
the number of programs so they reduce
the number of slots
fortunately gave us enough slots to
cover all of the existing students that
would have been a tragedy but it didn't
happen so now we have nine predock and
four postdoc slots steady-state many of
you rotate into them rotate out of them
and just like in the last cycle the
National Institute for dental and
craniofacial research funded
some slots in this round the National
Institute for environmental health
science Sciences funded two slots so
some of you are in those slots so that's
one fellowship and we're now in year
year 26 of the grant if you ever look at
the identifiers that NIH gives for
grants it has the identifiers you
usually in our case L M stands for
library medicine and then - and if
you're in the first year of your grant
like Michelle that's - a 1 and in the
case of this is - 26 we also have
another fellowship that we have created
for the clinical informatics
subspecialty again it's we were at the
forefront we were the fourth program
accredited Vishnu did all the work to
make sure that happened and in fact our
friend Chris Longhurst wrote a paper
about the experience of the first four
programs which we were part of what's
another interesting thing with the
fellowship is that the online courses
are actually very amenable to the
fellowship and so there are about a half
dozen other clinical informatics
fellowships from other places who are
employing our online courses and so they
take our courses interact with our not
not only our clinical informatics
fellows but also our other students and
and one thing I aim for in all of this
was one family of informatics education
and people's backgrounds and interests
and career goals are very different but
I've always thought there would be value
of having people together
certainly taking courses as much as
possible
so and then we have it's like a lot of
things we sort of stumbled into it and
it actually turned out to be a huge
thing back in 1999 when many people
access the internet with a telephone
modem people would be asking us you know
could you put your courses online so we
actually kind of as a little experiment
must have been in the summer of 99
ix actually hired one of our masters
students and she helped me put BMI 510
online and we taught at that fall and
you know the internet was a lot
different than at least half maybe two
thirds of the people connected by you
know 2400 baud or whatever though I get
56 cave baud modems and things like that
so we had to be very cognizant about
bandwidth and but it was successful and
people wanted more so that's why we
actually created the graduate
certificate program we didn't actually
think that people would want a master's
degree but they did so then we put the
clinical informatics track master's
degree online and maybe the rest is is
history but that did lead us to the
developer certificate that the eight
core subset of the master's and then
this this was also at a time when people
were starting to develop professional
master's degrees it it was recognized in
many fields that people wanted the
knowledge of the master's degree but
didn't necessarily want to do a long
research project and in fact we had a
number of students who were phenomenally
bright but for whatever reason that
really researchers and it really
provided them an opportunity to learn
more about informatics
than and and to not have to do a long
research project we did decide with the
master's program that if we were going
to award a master's degree they should
spend some time on our campus and we had
had some experience with other programs
of crunching it's actually one of the
advantages to the quarter system kind of
crunching a quarter program down to
basically a week so as you all know over
the summer now we usually teach several
courses in fact even the BCB tract has a
short course the analytics course with
the folks from Kaiser although it's
actually both tracks
another thing that's happened is the ten
by ten program which has also achieved
success in its own right what happened
was a Mia was looking for online
learning experiences and they were able
to find a lot of people who wanted to
charge them a lot of money for a small
amount of content BMI 510 was already
online it was sort of a perfect storm
and so I said you know let me make a
proposal and and we did and you know
basically repackaged BMI 510 as a
standalone introductory course and at
the time some of you know Charlie Safran
who was president of a Mia was going
around saying we need one physician and
one nurse in every hospital trained in
informatics so there's six thousand
hospitals in the US so I came up with
the idea well let's you train ten
thousand by twenty ten so ten by ten is
where that name comes from and then a
couple other things happen a number of
people wanted further study in fact
about fifteen or twenty percent of
people who do ten by ten actually enroll
in our master's program and even some of
you know Paula Otero
from Buenos Aires took the course and
translated into Spanish although since
then
to become very tailored to Latin America
but initially was was pretty much a
direct translation and so she's been
very successful with that and actually
we actually trained about a thousand
people by 2010 but there was still
interest and there continues to be
interest to this day so it just kind of
goes on as 10 by 10 even though it's
already seven years later and it's it's
been a great program
the program we've also been awarded
other grants we actually got a training
grant from NIH some of you remember our
Argentine fellows Alfredo and Charlie
and Sonya they're all doing great things
Alfredo's working for inner systems and
most Damien Bar Boulud now is a faculty
member at University of Utah so that
that's been a successful program
we got the large amount of money from
the high tech grant the stimulus dollars
more recently the bd2k and then updating
the health IT curriculum
we've also several in this room I see
but we actually I kind of liken it to we
were actually back in the 90s I tried to
convince the powers-that-be in the
School of Medicine yeah we should teach
some of this stuff to medical students
and it was so like wandering around the
desert and then George make I know some
of you know George who is our senior
associate dean for education led us into
the Promised Land
although fortunately I wasn't Moses so I
didn't have to like and that get to go
into the Promised Land but anyways we
we've actually quickly become and I I
can say this with a straight face we
have more clinical informatics now in
our MD curriculum than probably any
other
in the country it's also been
facilitated by the AMA grant that funded
some of the work and we've developed a
lot of activities for medical students
though it really at their kinds of
competencies so our medical students
well or I should say the average medical
student doesn't need to implement
machine learning algorithms or develop
fire queries and things like that but
they they need to know how to use
informatics tools in their care and
we've developed a lot of different
modalities EXCI Gretchen has also been
heavily involved with that to do various
things and being good academics we've
written about it it it's got my name
there but there's actually seven or
eight of us hit them all on the line but
I wrote a chapter describing everything
that we've done one thing we learned I'd
actually forgotten from my medical
education as medical students only study
stuff that's on the test and we didn't
actually create much assessment at the
beginning so they didn't do our stuff
because it wasn't on the test anyways so
we got stuff on the test now and so
they're they're doing informatics we've
also been involved with other learners
we have students from the hip program
the human investigations program we
actually that the bd2k educational
materials are our data science we some
of those modules are mapped to some of
those competencies for clinical and
translational researchers we've also
been involved there there's this process
going on it won't impact most of you in
the room but to transform PhD education
in the School of Medicine you may have
heard a little bit about it called
creative ideas it's still at least a
year down the road so it won't impact
you all much but it will actually
potentially bring us closer to and more
aligned with the rest of the PhD for
but right right now we're involved in
the planning process and we also have
our articulation with Portland State the
three plus two program that if one hits
the ground running at Portland State can
basically get a bachelor's degree and a
master's degree in five years and we the
they're relatively few students have
have actually completed that but the
option is there and and I'm hoping it
will grow to include other majors under
undergraduate majors so what have we
learned in all this so this is my kind
of take on it I've been over the last
few weeks as I've put these slides
together trying to kind of categorize
and summarize the and at lessons learned
and so actually this part I've been
interested in getting some feedback and
then I'm doing pretty well so I will
leave plenty of time for that
so so I kind of as I thought about it
broke it down into students and sort of
technology and modalities of learning
and then issues around the program and
support so students we we've certainly
seen a shift in informatics from as I've
already said formerly mostly academic
undertaking but now many professionals
kind of exemplified by the work that
goes on in clinical informatics and
clinical settings where it's really if
they're doing their job well taking and
applying informatics and then part of
that part of that's due to the shift
that we've seen of in in the early days
of the field the the real big programs
were those that had developed their
homegrown EHRs and as many of you know
one by one those systems are being
replaced mostly by epic and you know
Vanderbilt now partners
heck even the VA is planning probably
unfortunately because it's so widespread
and supportive but swapping out this
stuff or a certain or better or worse so
that's been a change in the field one
thing that we've always experienced in
this program is really to kind of
distinct well in that distinct it's
probably more of a continuum but
categories of learners the kind of first
career people who are relatively recent
maybe haven't finished their primary
training as opposed to especially in the
clinical side all those somewhat a few
in VCB who mid-career transitioning into
informatics and and and the oftentimes
those who are transitioning in
mid-career have jobs have families I
think that's part of the reason for the
success of the distance learning is that
people don't need to pick up and move to
Portland and become a full-time student
they can access it remotely another
interesting finding that I didn't really
think about initially but I chuckle when
I see it you know we've created this
virtual community I often see our online
students well maybe like at conferences
hanging out together but networking with
each other keeping track of each other
and two times at least I know is that
marriages some of you remember Darren
Nicholson and Michelle Lee and I
remember the other one now I can't but
anyways so we've facilitated a lot of
relationships
then another thing that we that this has
actually been a challenge for the
clinical training is actually getting
people to come to class we can't seem to
do that anymore
we we were able to do it a little bit
when we got all of the high tech funding
and we had a lot of on campus master's
students but we find many of you
actually prefer to take to listen to me
talk from the comfort of your own home
as opposed to having me stand up in
front of you like this so anyways that
that's been a challenge and I think
that's just a reality of Education and
that although the thing is with I think
we found with distance learning that
pretty much everything that one needs to
do can be done remotely I have Skype
calls with online students I they work
on projects and things like that there's
probably some difference to sitting
across the table from someone and
working on something but we've certainly
found joan used to use virtual projects
which i guess it got sidetracked because
of time zone differences and things like
that but you can certainly do a lot that
way in terms of the technology and
teaching modalities again i think pretty
much everything you can do in a
classroom can be replicated at least in
informatics you know maybe not in
learning a real hands-on skill like say
surgery but i'll talk a little bit about
lectures interaction assessment and i
actually have to mention i don't see any
of our Sakai folks here but the the
quality of support has has really
improved over the years and
is also help so we've been using
voiceover PowerPoint lectures literally
since the beginning and that's how I got
started in it some of you may remember
real media that's kind of gone by the
wayside but other tools and and we
currently mostly use articulate
presenter and and actually you there's
another big push in education for active
learning the idea of students being more
engaged and you might say well how can
acidly listening to a lecture more
engage people well when you chunk it
into smaller segments when you let
people started stopped you there's even
ways to interact with to make online
learning interactive you can introduce
some active learning kinds of technique
as opposed to a lecture where I'm just
sitting here standing here talking and
if your mind wanders on to something
else which I'm sure it will I usually do
too you may miss have missed something
that I said so I actually have a
screenshot of this is you know my famous
slide about information retrieval this
is whenever it was probably like in 1999
or so and this is what I captured a
screenshot of a few days ago it there
are some differences although the
content is the same so how far have we
come
another nice thing about articulate
presenter is that you can well actually
you can record it slide by slide but you
can also listen to it slide by slide so
you can navigate around and go back
things like that in fact you know
certainly I've spent a lot of my time
will have my life in the last I guess
almost two decades in front of these
sorts of tools and an articulate
presenter is pretty good and and my
purpose in putting this up here as I
will deliver this talk to the educators
next week is to just many of them are
interested in these sorts of tools and
many
ninety-two there right now I'm not aware
I'm constantly on the lookout and I
would change in a minute if something
better came along but articulate
presenter is probably the best tool
available it works as a plug-in to
Windows PowerPoint it a real nice
feature of it is you can narrate one
slide at a time so if something changes
on one slide you don't have to re-record
your whole lecture students notice it
that the background noise might change
or things like that but it makes it
easier to update things and it used to
have the problem of only outputting
flash but now it outputs html5 you can
create mp3 files and so forth and and it
works relatively well on mobile devices
the cons is that it's a it's a pretty
expensive product although in the larger
scheme of things it's you know when you
look at all the other expenses the
program has including salaries of people
it's it's relatively small and then of
course as you know many of us are Mac
users it doesn't there's no native Mac
version so I you know fire up my
parallels virtual machine and bring up
now Windows 10 on my new Mac and I use
articulate presenter that way and it's a
little clunky but it works so there's
also we've learned to interact well with
online classes the you know classic
threaded discussion forums which if you
can keep people from flaming and and
otherwise being unprofessional work
pretty well we had have had the ability
to do real-time video I haven't made a
huge use of it but I know some of the
other faculty have and OHSU is
transitioning to this new next
which is based on Cisco meeting and then
the virtual projects which I always
thought were an interesting idea to
enable students to work together
assessment I have to say that our
informatics students aren't quite as not
studying something because it's not on
the test but assessment is important we
have to make sure that you've gained the
knowledge the competencies again many
things can be done online another
interesting thing is I was once a
medical student in the the bane of
medical students as multiple choice
questions and I swore that I would never
if I ever taught I would never use
multiple-choice questions I love
multiple-choice questions there they're
actually an effective way to test people
in fact I often found with short answer
questions that it was a kind of rote
memory thing so I personally like
multiple-choice questions and then of
course we have the issue of high stakes
exams
unfortunately not everyone upholds the
code of honor of these sorts of things
and so on some challenges with the
virtual proctoring as you experience
with examity so a few comments about the
program the next day then I'll wrap it
up I've learned well this is true with
the department and also with the
academic program if it's a business it's
a noble business but it's a business
nonetheless and we have to make sure
that the kind of business aspects of the
program are attended to the sakai folks
over the years have been wonderful my
initial hesitation when we actually used
to run a server that back when
blackboard was actually much cheaper we
used to have a UNIX server that was
running blackboard and when Sakai came I
was really hesitant because there's a
history at this institution of IT things
being less than optimally supported but
the tom
DRO who's now retired but was the
original head of the Sakai group and he
did a tremendous job we've also learned
that responding to students even folks
such as yourself who are on campus here
but the online students even if it's
just a response to tell them that you
will get back to them just to
acknowledge that they're there it's I
mean I sort of certainly find this and
other things of what I do when you send
an email and then you don't hear back
after days weeks whatever I actually
have a paper that's sitting under review
at a journal and I haven't heard
anything in five months although I've
queried them a few times it's kind of
frustrating so just you know being
timely in your responses to to people
that we have a policy you all should
know that in fact this applies to all
faculty not just online faculty that we
have an initial response back to
students and within two business days of
when the email was received a few other
lessons I've learned I live a very
asynchronous life all of the teaching I
do is asynchronous with you know so I
don't have to find if I'm travelling I
don't have to find a substitute on the
other hand oftentimes the first thing I
do like when I got to Thailand last week
check my email check my Sakai it's what
I call living the asynchronous life that
human connection to learners is still
really important the technology is an
enabler it's not really a replacement
for human contact one interesting thing
is that Oh a chess use success from all
you in informatics education it's being
replicated by many people in fact that
with the clinical informatics
fellowships
Vanderbilt is
asking programs you know you can take
courses with us and then also facing
competition from other new types of
Education like MOOCs I I think MOOCs are
interesting massive open online courses
they I never really thought they would
replace higher education they're
certainly and there's certainly tons of
great content out there but education is
more than just delivering lectures as
we've learned in this program so the I
think the the place for MOOCs is still
kind of working its way out so in
conclusion I think we all should be
proud of the success that we've achieved
in making the making the world a better
place for informatics and not not only
for informatics professionals but
disseminating to larger the larger
public the technology is important it's
like everything the informatics the
technology is important but
understanding the needs in the case of
Education competencies delivering
content managing the program and again
for the folks that I talked to next week
because one of the challenges in
academia is is how to achieve the
productivity or the fruits of active
academic success grants writing papers
things like that I think we've shown
that we do that quite well
many of us have published papers and so
forth and managed to get a few grants
along the way so this is my last slide
I'm just gonna leave this up here asking
anything you want to talk about we have
about 10 10 or so minutes left anything
any comments on the slides
anything you comments suggestions
constructive criticisms about the
program or anything I didn't talk about
that faculty should really be thinking
about have added an X I'm going to join
the beginning of the fellows meeting and
talk about those things there so Lynn
has the microphone so you don't have to
push and Annie has his hand up I think
we kind of talked about this little bit
bill but I'd just like to hear your
thoughts again when teaching medical
students about EHRs how do you decide or
kind of plan out the process of making
the their experience as EHR agnostic as
possible to avoid them just becoming
mm-hmm you know when their medical
students at OHSU they're gonna become
epic users and then force them even more
down the road to say I want to work at a
residency as epic or be an attending at
a place that has that big how do you
kind of think about the process of when
you're designing their curriculum make
it as EHR agnostic as possible sure now
yeah that's that's a challenge it's it's
a challenge for the whole world for the
whole country because almost all
academic medical centers now are using
epic the competencies are written very
generically and they're the kinds of
things that you need to do like trend
labs enter orders use clinical decision
support we try I think we try to you
know to emphasize that and oh this is
how it's done in epic and you know
unfortunately especially in the city
like this when they go to Kaiser when
they go to an ocean clinic that they're
they're just using more epic although
you know the old adage if you've seen
one instance of epic you've seen one
instance of epic but still it's
important to teach them the concepts in
fact that's we tell the curricular
leaders that you know that's one of the
reasons why we want to teach the way
that we do so there it isn't just about
learning epic
as a follow-up to that has there been
any discussion with the EHR vendors of
potentially offering may be an
educational instance of their EHR so
that an institution can't have multiple
versions without having to purchase the
you know extended like a full kind of
version of Cerner we can just have an
educational instance of Cerner so that
OHSU has multiple options available as
that yeah I'm sure that question comes
up but you know I know that epics answer
to that is that well you know if you're
an epic customer you can do you can do
anything
health professions education related you
want with epic we pay actually pay epic
by the transaction so it doesn't cost us
anything we have our virtual server our
virtual version of epic which XE you all
have access to and in it well there's a
cost to the department and that we have
to pay for the server but there's
there's not a cost - Oh a chess you I I
don't know that the vendors would be
then enthusiastic about it but I don't
know I've never really been involved in
those conversations or yeah Aaron
if the vendor if you have the vendor thr
and the clinical systems like Bill is
saying they're pretty flexible about
using it for education but if you want
another vendors they're not so I mean
I've had talks with Cerner about this
and they're not they're not interested
what they would like to sell you you
know access to their education or
whatever so they're also looking at it
as a way to make money but if they're
already have a huge contract with
flexible epic started with us and now
they have you know fleshed out a whole
program for using their EHR education
with their customers I don't know
specifically happens plans are charging
people who aren't their customers yeah I
do know that Cerner has created an
online accessible version of their EHR
to to sell basically for sell seats for
education
yeah EPIK does not have any plan to help
other institutions who are not using
epic with any kind of educational
process they send out a standard
response of this is something we're
thinking about and we'll reach out when
the time comes and and pretty soon if
you wanted hands-on with Cerner you'll
just be able to walk across the bridge I
was told by some folks from Portland VA
that they actually may be the first
instance of Cerner you know Cerner
signed the contract with the Department
of Defense and then the current
administration decided that it would
make a lot of sense to have the VA using
the same system as the Department of
Defense so the VA without really any
kind of competitive bidding processes is
getting Cerner
yeah I actually think it's very amazing
the whole online program that this
department has created I have a question
about the online part that as someone
who does telemedicine no research I'm
actually more and more thinking that
there are some things that are difficult
to relieve to replicate it with my
patients remotely that I can do in
person and you know I think we see that
in the hybrid class where I think that
there are things that the students get
out of being in person that they can't
remotely and you know you know people
who do NIH grant reviews you know
there's the in-person review versus that
phone conference versus the moderated
discussion threads and I personally
believe that the in-person one is still
sort of there are things that are tough
to do and so I'm curious what your
thoughts are about moving forward
do you and maybe there's a question for
everybody think that there are some
areas that we could be doing to sort of
better replicate something that's
missing in the I online parts I'm
actually having trouble figuring out
what that is but I know you thought
about it well I you know actually
similar to telemedicine you know we we
really shouldn't think of online
necessarily as a replacement for
face-to-face learning and I agree I mean
there there there still is nothing of
you know especially especially a
and a real advance student like PhD
student you know that's why we actually
we occasionally talked about but we've
never really seriously thought by
putting a PhD program online because
there is that sort of you know when
you're in a mentor-mentee kind of
relationship I'm sure there's probably
things that that are missing but you
know it's just like you know again
telemedicine is not really meant to be a
replacement for a face-to-face care it's
meant to provide care when you can't
couldn't otherwise do it you know so
being out in the rural area or an
elderly infirm person who can't get out
of their home and so forth
and so you know I think that for many
people who would not be able to to have
informatics education this provides a
way now that's it on the other hand I'm
thinking as I'm saying that I just told
you guys that we can't I mean this is a
phenomena certainly a phenomena in the
medical school you know they record all
the lectures and a lot of the medical
students choose to just watch them from
the convenience of their own home
especially if they can double-time them
and they you know it goes much faster
they don't come to campus so so I don't
know that that is a that is a good
question but you know I think that gets
to it you know a online we used to like
completely separate you know you're
either online or on campus and that
distinction has kind of gone away so so
yeah I think we need to think about how
we can make it the learning experience
better
you know remote
yeah
thanks I enjoyed the presentation I
don't question around the last bullet
point what else should faculty be
thinking about it's just an idea Ani
mentioned like the access to electronic
health records and I was thinking but
the last part of it but then there's
access to data as well and there's
access to de-identified data sets that
you can look at from like you know other
hospital settings but we know in
informatics that the organizational part
and the data part I mean like the
workflow and the data it's you can't
really separate the two and if you study
a de-identified data set you don't have
access to the work environment that's
around that so I think there's an
opportunity to potentially provide
access to work environments and data
associated with those work environments
on a concurrent basis and it might be
really fosters and really exciting
student projects yeah yeah no no I agree
you know de-identified data loses the
fidelity that's the the project that
well Steven woo is take moved down but
that Steven vedric and I are doing with
NLP around patient records and you know
but it's a challenge because it's highly
personal data we have I shouldn't even
talk too much about it a significant
subset of OHSU data on a highly secure
server in the ACC that'll actually be a
good question when the new chief
information security officer comes and
but you're absolutely right having you
know the data is everything now and
getting access to the data is really
critical and we're aware of that
maybe we have time for one more question
or or no more
okay well very good thank you all and
we'll have another speaker next week
[Applause]